I am with secret songwriter Grammy
winner and 2023 nominee Ella Mae Ella
you ready to shake things up I'm always
ready to shake things off
[Music]
give us a little tease about your
Grammy's look because you have turned it
out in the past like I'm still thinking
about that long navy blue train yeah
everybody on the copy that hey if me
hate amazing because it was just so long
I was in everyone's way I will say I
have changed a part of my look
drastically so it might be a surprise
hopefully everyone still recognizes me
what inspired that like this change
um a lot of things I think like also
like releasing that album is like it's
almost like a rebirth I think and I just
wanted to kind of uh
spice things up a bit I just you know
before her new tour kicks off Ella will
be celebrating with the best voices in
music so we teamed up with Ella and the
official Spirit partner of the 65th
annual Grammy Awards Gray Goose so you
can sip like the stars the Grammys is
the biggest mountain music and Just Like
Music and having elements to add into a
perfect song we have to add the Perfect
Vodka into the perfect cocktail
so what is the official cocktail and
more importantly how do we make it we're
gonna be making yeah the passenger okay
we're gonna start with the most
essential part of the cocktail with some
Gray Goose
an ounce and a half we're making a
passion drop so of course we have to
have passion fruit juice passion fruit
half an ounce
that smells so good the next one we have
is ginger syrup do a half ounce again
and then we have another half ounce of
lemon juice and the last one we have is
simple syrup
at this point passion drop
we need to finish and touch of course
Tada come on now these look so good I'm
proud of us I'm a cheers to you
congratulations and have so much fun
this weekend come on Grammys cheers
foreign